Narrator: This is Jim.
He's cleaning the reflecting pools
at the 9/11 Memorial in New York City.
Jim and his team are working beneath
a 27-foot-tall waterfall
in near-total darkness,
vacuuming every inch of the pool.
Their goal is to do it
without missing a spot.
It's a physically demanding job,
but that's not the only challenge.
Jim: I've never actually
marked how many miles it is,
but you do a few miles in there,
and it could be humid,
and you come out of there
and you feel like you
walked on the moon, almost.
Narrator: The pools are
nearly an acre each,
so it will take hours to finish the job
before the sun comes up.
While he works inside the pool,
other crew members work on
the bronze panels aboveground.
These routines happen five
days a week and are essential
for keeping the memorial
in pristine condition
for the millions who come
to pay their respects here.
They start by shutting off the waterfalls,
and over the next eight hours,
Jim and his team work tirelessly
to deep clean this pool.
Jim: The hardest part is it's a long task.
The pool is big. It's not a swimming pool.
It's a 200-by-200 giant pool.
I'm going to pull the hose
out and then bring it back.
Rian: Gotcha.
Jim: You don't have to use the whole reel.
We got too much hose.
We usually have three
men through the pool,
so two guys will be in the pool
and one guy will be
outside running the pumps,
which collect the debris
and return the clean
water back to the pool.
Once we're set, we're on our way.
I go and vacuum, generally,
and whoever's with me
that night brushes behind.
Come on, hurry up.
Rian: Sorry.
Jim: We don't got all day here.
The vacuum will capture
most of the debris,
and the person brushing will knock up
some of the other loose debris
that doesn't get caught,
and it will be caught
into some of our filters
that we have running downstairs.
Now I'm trapped in the hose here.
I'm going to trip myself.
And we'll be on "America's Bloopers."
Narrator: The workers generally
clean out dirt, leaves,
and algae from the bottom of the pools.
They also remove larger items
that visitors drop or throw in.
They don't always know
what they'll encounter
in the pool each night.
Jim: We find kids' toys,
little small items.
Depends on the crowd.
One night I actually found a bat in there.
And I'm not talking about a baseball bat,
I'm talking about a bat.
It was pretty wild when
he flew away from me
when I realized I was grabbing a bat.
Depending on the cleanliness of the pool,
it could take anywhere between
six and seven hours.
And sometimes, if we feel up to it,
we could do it a little quicker.
Some people treat this
place like a wishing well.
So we do catch some money,
and unfortunately I think some people,
being that it's so far removed
from the original 9/11,
I think some people are a little
uneducated about this place,
and some people treat it
like just a regular fountain,
and they're throwing garbage
in here sometimes too.
People have to learn that
this isn't your mall fountain.
I knew a few of the
brokers that passed away,
a whole group of them who had a meeting
in one of the towers, unfortunately, and,
except for one trader,
all of them perished.
I think about them often
because we go up top where the names are
and brush near the
nameplates, the troughs,
and on the north side,
they're all on one panel.
So I see their names just about every day.
Total waste of lives
that could have been doing
good in the world now.
Narrator: While Jim and the team
finish cleaning the pools below,
Ryan is tackling the
bronze name panels above.
The panels honor the 2,983
victims of the attacks
on the World Trade Center,
both in 1993 and 2001.
Ryan will have to strip
the top layer of metal
and use a blowtorch to remove a carving
someone etched onto the plaque,
without damaging the rest of the memorial.
Ryan: Confuses me why you'd
want to write something here.
For a mark like that,
you have to go pretty
deep, get all the way down.
Otherwise you can't really get rid of it.
If you don't go down far enough,
you'll see it when you refinish it.
The further down you go, the better.
Sometimes I've seen nice things written,
but, you know, they don't understand.
You can't just write
whatever you want on it.
Narrator: After briefly
assessing the damage,
Ryan needs to remove the protective bars
so he can reach the entire metal surface.
To do this, he props up
the bars with a wood plank
and unhooks the brackets
holding up the panels.
Ryan: Whew!
Now what I'll do is rub
it down with the naphtha.
It's almost like a paint thinner.
It just kind of takes the wax
off, so I'm not burning wax.
If I can open it.
And it shouldn't take too long
once I get the torch on it.
There's so much in the prep,
and then the finishing,
the torch is actually not that bad.
Narrator: After sanding
down the top layer of panel
and neutralizing the wax,
Ryan is ready to
blowtorch the damaged area
to melt the metal in the patina
so he can repaint the color layer
and restore the panel
to its original state.
Ryan: This is what we use,
and it's basically just
a patina in a solution.
Ah, I haven't used you in a while.
Prep them.
So, I'm basically getting
up to the right temperature.
If it's too cold, it'll go on spotty.
If it's too hot, it'll
kind of evaporate off
or it'll get burnt.
Narrator: In the summer months,
the longest part of the job
is waiting for the burned panel to cool
before applying a new layer
of wax and an acrylic topcoat
to finish the restoration process.
We're going to put the
acrylic spray on it,
just kind of like a clear coat.
It helps it kind of adhere
a little bit better.
The last step, really. Well,
besides buffing the wax off.
So I'm just going to put
the wax on real nice.
Not too hard, not a lot.
You don't need a ton.
Just put it on lightly.
The wax will go over the
finish and make it look,
once I polish it, it'll look brand new.
We got a little bit of heat,
but that's because it's still hot.
But it was right here.
Narrator: Now all Ryan has to
do is buff off the excess wax
using a white Scotch-Brite pad.
Ryan: And then once it gets
smooth, you know you're done.
When people do something like that,
I wouldn't say it makes
me angry. I get it.
Some of these people might
not have even been alive
when it happened, or they
were too young to get it.
My uncle was a New York City firefighter,
and he was hurt really bad here,
but luckily he survived.
We got a little lucky.
Narrator: After a strenuous
six to seven hours of cleaning,
Jim and the team are ready
to head out of the pool.
By tomorrow morning, a
new batch of visitors
will see sparkling pools
below rushing waterfalls,
and most of them won't know
that Jim's team was even here.
Jim: When we finish the
pool, most of the time,
we're just ready to
really get out of there.
And most of our inspection,
we're fairly confident
that we did the proper job.
There's always a little fail factor,
but not too bad.
My father worked in these
buildings almost his whole life.
And my father was here
for the '93 bombing,
and that was before
cellphones and everything,
and he was on the 30th
floor of the second tower.
When he was there, he
was the floor marshal.
He came home full of
soot, but he stayed there
because there was people that
couldn't get down the steps.
So he made sure that he stayed with them.
So I think on 9/11 day, if he was here,
we probably would've lost him
because he wouldn't have left.
He passed away a couple years ago.
He was always so proud of the job.
I probably had chances to do
other things in this building,
but even if I wanted to do another job,
I wouldn't, because of him.
And now, I love doing it, so I do it.